[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
paris einen schönen guten abend und
willkommen für den sport im studio
norbert lehmann ein schillernder familie
unsere großen themen in dieser sendung
gemeinsame grenzpatrouillen angesichts
steigender flüchtlingszahlen aus belarus
setzt innenminister seehofer auf die
zusammenarbeit mit polen
eine frau an der parlamentsspitze die
spd politikerin bärbel bar soll
bundestagspräsidentin werben
und vorzeitiger rückzug bundesbank
präsident weidmann gibt sein amt nach
zehn jahren auf
2015 und 16 waren ganz andere
größenordnungen was die zahl der
flüchtlinge angeht so der
bundesinnenminister
gleichzeitig äußerte sich seehofer aber
heute alarmiert darüber dass der
belarussische machthaber lukaschenko
immer mehr menschen aus dem irak syrien
oder afghanistan in die eu schließt die
geflüchteten werden von und über belarus
gezielt zur polnischen eu außengrenze
gebracht von dort machen sich immer mehr
auf den weg nach ostdeutschland mehr als
5600 menschen würden seit beginn des
jahres im deutsch polnischen grenzgebiet
aufgegriffen der bundesinnenminister
will die illegale einreise stoppen
andrea maurer
stichpunkt kontrolle der bundespolizei
grenzbrücke frankfurt oder
jeden tag werden an der deutsch
polnischen grenze gerade 100 bis 150
menschen aufgegriffen die der
belarussische machthaber lukaschenko als
flüchtlinge wohl gezielt in die irre
schleust am morgen hat der innenminister
das kabinett informiert
das ist eine form der hybriden bedrohung
in dem man migranten als politische
waffe einsetzt menschen würden es
braucht sagt seehofer er sieht
verantwortung auch in moskau ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen und da hat mir
heute auch niemand widersprochen im
kabinett dass das regime in belarus dies
alles machen kann ohne
zumindestens
inkaufnahme oder billigung aus moskau
der innenminister will nun die
kontrollen erhöhen 800 schafften sind in
das deutsch polnische grenzgebiet
verlegt worden gemeinsam mit polnischen
kollegen soll verstärkt kontrolliert
werden eine grenzschließung schließt das
kabinett aus es gibt jetzt auch darum
den flugverkehr nach belarus zu
unterbinden es kommt flüge nach minsk
aus ländern außerhalb der europäischen
union da müssen wir ansetzen wir müssen
gucken dass diese flüge unterbunden
werden und dass dieser staatlich
organisierter menschenhandel gestoppt
wird flüchtlinge die den weg durch polen
nach deutschland geschafft haben
berichten von einer kräftezehrenden
flucht auf ihren handys bilder von
menschen die vor lauter durst unterwegs
aus pfützen trinken
mehrere bundesländer stellen sich nun
auf steigende flüchtlingszahlen 1 allein
in brandenburg ist die zahl der
schutzsuchenden in der erstaufnahme im
oktober schon auf über 2.000 gestiegen
noch steht die neue koalition nicht aber
die erste top personal je nach der wahl
ist wohl entschieden präsidentin des
neuen bundestages soll die
stellvertretende fraktionschefin der spd
bärbel bas werden das amt steht der
größten fraktion im parlament so die 53
jährige sitzt seit 2009 im bundestag und
befasst sich vor allem mit gesundheit
bildung und forschung
vorher gab es aus der eigenen partei
kritik dass die spd bereits zwei der
drei höchsten staatsämter mit männern
besetzt hat oder besetzen will so strebt
olaf scholz ins kanzleramt und frank
walter steinmeier will bundespräsident
bleiben
kontaktmanager welches signal geht denn
von dieser personalentscheidung aus die
spd löst damit jetzt vorerst zumindest
zwei probleme auf einen schlag nämlich
zum einen wendet sie den eindruck ab
dass sie sich im wahlkampf die
gleichstellung auf die fahnen schreibt
und diese dann bei der ersten
gelegenheit wieder über bord wirft und
zum anderen verhindert sie das jetzt
schon ein geschacher um das amt des
bundespräsidenten ausbricht denn wer
hätte sie diese position des
bundestagspräsidenten jetzt präsidentin
nicht weiblich besetzt dann hätte wäre
die das nächste amt dass dafür in frage
gekommen wäre eben das von frank walter
steinmeier gewesen darüber hätte man
dann verhandeln müssen dass es jetzt
erst mal aus der welt aber das ganze ist
eben nur eine entwarnung für den moment
der morgen beginnen die
koalitionsverhandlungen mit fdp und
grünen
da steht dann auch das versprechen von
olaf scholz im raum sein kabinett zur
hälfte mit männern und zur hälfte mit
frauen zu besetzen
das wird dann sicherlich nochmal
eingefordert werden das haben wir jetzt
anhand der kritik aus gesellschaft und
aus den eigenen spd rhein wir sehen das
macht die verhandlungen ein wenig
komplizierter da sitzt dann aber nicht
mehr nur die spd alleine da und steht
unter druck sondern da sitzen spd fdp
und grüne mit im boot vielen dank für
diese einschätzung ist content manager
um personalien in der möglichen
ampelkoalition soll es also erst geben
wenn spd grüne und fdp die inhalte durch
verhandelt haben 22 arbeitsgruppen
setzten sich dafür am morgen zusammen
mit insgesamt fast 300 beteiligten ein
großer brocken die frage woher das geld
kommen soll für die vorhaben ohne
steuererhöhungen und ohne aufweichung
der schuldenbremse thomas reichert hat
sich das angeschaut
das zumindest ist geklärt die
koalitionsverhandlungen beginnen morgen
dort wo die sondierungsgespräche letzte
woche endete in einem messegebäude im
berliner westen ungeklärt ist dagegen
die geldfrage robert habeck fordert
erneut rund 50 milliarden euro pro jahr
auch über kredite zu finanzieren die
öffentliche hand wird ihre
investitionstätigkeit deutlich ausweiten
und die investition die investition in
die zukunft technologien digitalisierung
und klimaschutz tätigen das heißt ja und
dabei beharrt der schuldenbremse werden
wir kredite aufnehmen ganz ähnlich sieht
es auch die spd deren parteivorsitzender
erklärt bei investitionen in die zukunft
ist aber auch eine teilweise
finanzierung mit krediten gerechtfertigt
es gebe bei der schuldenbremse da
durchaus spielräume nur welche
spielräume eine idee nicht der staat
sondern staatliche unternehmen wie die
bahn nehmen kredite für investitionen
auf es gibt öffentliche unternehmen zb
die waren die ja wichtige investitionen
tätigen zum beispiel bahnstrecken bauen
mit modernisieren ausbauen hier kann der
bund sich verschulden jedenfalls erlaubt
ihm dass die schuldenbremse daneben
könnte die staatliche kfw bank kredite
aufnehmen um investitionen zu fördern
auch die fdp zieht er offenbar keine
roten linien was wir in den blick nehmen
müssen ist die möglichkeit privates
kapital zu mobilisieren etwa durch
investitionsanreize und natürlich müssen
wir auch die möglichkeiten der kfw
nutzen weitere milliarden erhoffen sich
die ampel verhandler davon
klimaschädliche subventionen zu kürzen
oder steuerbetrug schärfer zu verfolgen
ob das reicht bei der frage beginnt nun
das große rechnen
apropos finanzen bundesbank präsident
jens weidmann hat überraschend
angekündigt zurückzutreten aus
persönlichen gründen wie er sagt eine
entscheidung die auch deshalb mit
argusaugen verfolgt wird weil weit man
stets die ultralockere geldpolitik der
europäischen zentralbank den niedrigen
zinsen kritisiert kritisiert hat peter
wagner über das ausscheiden des obersten
währungshüters zum jahresende
die bundesbank in frankfurt kantig eckig
klare linien die ezb nicht weit davon
geschwungen flexibel weiche formen
architektur die auf teils
unterschiedlicher vorstellungen
widerspiegelt so kann man weidmanns
abschiedsbrief an sein team verstehen
eine stabilitätsorientierte geldpolitik
wird dauerhaft nur möglich sein wenn der
ordnungsrahmen der währungsunion die
einheit von handeln und haften sichert
die geldpolitik ihr enges mandat achtet
und nicht ins schlepptau der
fiskalpolitik oder der finanzmärkte
gerät
weidmann hoch angesehen in der deutschen
öffentlichkeit war mehr und mehr
isoliert im ezb rat seine mahnungen vor
den inflationsgefahren der ausufernden
anleihekäufe fanden kaum gehör
ich erwarte nach dem rücktritt von herrn
weidmann mehr denn je dass die ezb auch
nach einem ende des pep
anleihekaufprogramms weiter im großen
stil staatsanleihen kaufen wird mit
weidmanns rückzug kommt neuer zündstoff
in das personaltableau der ampel
koalitionäre noch finanzminister scholz
würdigte seine verdienste
grünen-chef habeck sieht die chance für
eine modernisierung der bundesbank und
die fdp warnt vor inflation
die deutsche bundesbank muss weiter
anwältin einer stabilitätsorientierten
geldpolitik in europa bleiben wir sehen
inzwischen
inflationsrisiken in europa die ezb ist
zur eigenen macht am main geworden daran
wird auch der oder die künftige
bundesbank präsidenten kaum etwas ändern
valerie haller an der frankfurter börse
hohe preise niedrige zinsen viele
menschen in deutschland sind
verunsichert was bedeutet der rücktritt
weit man es als bundesbank-präsident in
dieser zeit ja das bedeutet dass europa
einen neinsager verliert in einer zeit
in der das neinsagen vermutlich wichtig
wäre die ezb muss ja zurzeit die rasant
steigende inflation in den griff
bekommen und wird dafür in den nächsten
wochen entscheidende weichen stellen ja
die frage wird sein ob die ezb weiter
macht mit ihrem pandemie notpaket oder
ob sie das programm auslaufen lässt ein
programm das vor allem schuldengeplagten
ländern in der eurozone hilft deswegen
es viele befürworter hat weidmann war
kritiker und damit ziemlich allein auf
weiter flur in finanzkreisen fürchtet
man nun dass sein nachfolger seine
nachfolgerin er jemand sein könnte der
der mehrheitsmeinung folgt also die
ultralockere geldpolitik
unterstützt noch ist aber völlig offen
wer das sein könnte zu seinem abschied
jedenfalls weit man kann es nicht lassen
warnt er noch mal vor inflationsgefahren
die solle die ezb nicht aus dem blick
verlieren
dankeschön valerie haller
eine private söldner truppe rekrutiert
aus bundeswehr und polizeikreisen das
war offenbar der plan zwei ex soldaten
die seit heute in haft sitzen laut
bundesanwaltschaft wollten die beiden
männer mit einer einheit in den
bürgerkrieg im jemen eingreifen ihr
motiv geld sie wollten sich von dritten
finanzieren lassen vorrangig von saudi
arabien
ermittelt wird nun wegen der versuchten
gründung einer terroristischen
vereinigung
schauen wir auf die pandemie und
beginnen mit den corona zahlen für
deutschland
die zahl der neuinfektionen steigt hier
weiter an das robert koch institut
meldet 17.000 15 fälle innerhalb eines
tages
5112 mehr als vor einer woche
92 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
19 binnen 24 stunden der sieben tage ins
event steigt auf 80,4
deutlich dramatischer
die lage in russland die zahl der korona
toten so hoch wie nie die
infektionszahlen deutlich gestiegen und
nur jeder dritte ist geimpft die
regierung will jetzt gegensteuern und
verhängt betriebsferien ab dem 30
oktober sollen alle arbeitnehmer in
russland für eine woche zu hause bleiben
kündigte präsident putin an lohn gebe es
trotzdem allein gestern zählte das land
mehr als 1000 corona tote
ein weiteres land das von corona
besonders hart getroffen wurde ist
brasilien das liegt an der politik zu
diesem schluss kommt ein jetzt
veröffentlichter untersuchungsbericht
inzwischen hat sich in brasilien
mindestens jeder zehnte mit corona
infiziert mehr als 600.000 menschen
starben im zusammenhang mit kubik 19 die
schuld daran gibt der bericht vor allem
präsident boyzone euro er habe gegen
alle ratschläge der expertinnen und
experten gehandelt corona verharmlost
und auf herdenimmunität gesetz statt
aufs impfen christoph rath mit den
einzelheiten
er war keine nummer er war ein
wunderbarer junger mensch wie so viele
andere ein vater trauert um seinen an
corona verstorbenen sohn während seiner
aussage vor dem untersuchungsausschuss
ein halbes jahr lang haben die senatoren
das verhalten der regierung während der
pandemie untersucht ihr fazit sie werfen
präsident goldstone awo im umgang mit
corona verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit und weitere straftaten
vor
die bundesregierung deren verpflichtung
es gewesen wäre etwas zu tun hat
stattdessen will endlich den tod von
brasilianern und brasilianerinnen in
kauf genommen der präsident hat viele
verbrechen begangen und er wird dafür
bezahlen
tausende tote wären vermeidbar gewesen
hätte sich boll szenario an die
empfehlungen der wissenschaft gehalten
so der bericht doch boll szenario hat
das corona virus von anfang an
verharmlost stimmung gemacht gegen
lockdown maßnahmen masken tragen und die
impfung stattdessen pries er
nachweislich wirkungslose mittel an
alles um seine basis mobilisieren
ideologie glaube gefühle fake news statt
fakten
es zeigt was für ein risiko von
populistischen regierungen ausgeht sie
produzieren eine humanitäre katastrophe
sterben viel mehr menschen als sterben
müssten der bericht ist eine bislang
einzigartige abrechnung mit der korona
politik eines staatschefs eine
amtsenthebung werden szenarios
verbündete im parlament wohl verhindern
können doch sein image dürfte nachhaltig
schaden nehmen seit monaten schon wächst
der unmut gegen wollten euro nächstes
jahr wird gewählt die senatoren wollen
ihren bericht der
bundesstaatsanwaltschaft und dem
internationalen gerichtshof vorlegen
276 tage so lange sitzt der russische
oppositionelle alexej nawalny schon in
haft nun hat das europäische parlament
entschieden der 45-jährige erhält den
diesjährigen sacharow preis für seinen
mutigen einsatz gegen korruption und für
menschenrechte er habe unermüdlich für
grundlegende freiheiten in seinem land
gekämpft so die begründung
dies habe ihn seine eigene freiheit und
fast sein leben gekostet im vergangenen
jahr hatte navalny nur knapp einen
giftanschlag überlebt
und wir kommen zur
fußball-champions-league norbert daher
gestern die beiden deutschen feine
verloren ja aber vielleicht machen das
hier heute abend wolfsburg und münchen
besser als dortmund und leipzig rb
bislang schwachen der königsklasse aber
gestern abend gegen das star-ensemble
aus paris ein starker auftritt der
leipziger trotz der knappen 2
3-niederlage
der kleine unterschied messi macht es
möglich seine balleroberung dann
julian draxler zu mbp das 1 0 für psg im
prinzenpark-stadion
er will hat sich aber auf augenhöhe der
ausgleich durch andre silva durchaus
verdient und in der zweiten halbzeit der
scheinbare befreiungsschlag die erbe
führung durch diesen treffer von mykene
wir sind schon aber so weit weg die
stars vom psc machen letztlich den
unterschied mbp auf messi der ausgleich
dieses foul und messis ausgebuffte
umsetzung des elfmeters zum 3 2-endstand
leipzig über weite strecken gut aber
eben nicht gut genug
dortmund dagegen gestern mit einem
phasenweise desolaten auftritt gegen
ajax amsterdam die schwächste leistung
der borussia in dieser saison die 0
4-klatsche gegen den begeisternden
niederländischen meister durchaus
verdient der gesichtsausdruck des
siegtorschützen zum 4 0 sagt alles über
die mangelhafte leistungen der
dortmunder haben die mich wirklich
derart drei stehen lassen scheint der
verdutzte sebastian alea sich zu fragen
in anbetracht der schwachen
zweikampfführung des bvb die dortmunder
weit unter den eigenen ansprüchen das
eigentor von reus zum 1 0 mag ja noch
als pech durchgehend die weiteren
treffer wie das 2 0 von blind aber
blitzsauber herausgespielte begeistert
gefeiert nur erling forlan hätte nochmal
verkürzen können nach der pause aber
ging dortmund endgültig unter erst
anthony zum 13 0 und dann auch wie
gesehen all er für ajax fans ein
wunderbarer abend
und die zusammenfassungen der partien
vom dritten spieltag sehen sie heute
abend bei uns von 23 uhr an im
sportstudio uefa champions league und
auch online gibt es alle spiele und alle
tore kompakt ab 23 uhr bei heute de und
in der zdf- heute
gibt sie zu gucken oder abend
und jetzt werden wir noch einen blick in
den süden deutschlands wo der goldene
oktober seinem namen alle ehre sonne
tanken das genossen einheimische
touristinnen und touristen heute vor
allem am und auf dem wasser wie hier am
tegernsee für den sprung hinein brauchte
es aber mehr mut kaum sonne aber sehr
viel wind dagegen auf dem brocken gut
festhalten oder festhalten lassen hier
das oberste gebot ähnlich ungemütlich
und gefährlich soll es morgen auch in
tieferen lagen werden
und mittwoch zeit also für die
lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten 7 15
16 24 37 43 und die superzahl 5 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und dem zdf text auf seite 5 157
dass der sturm kommt hat mir ja schon
katja hornuf erklärt gleich genau worauf
wir uns einstellen sollten und hier
steht um 21.45 marietta slomka mit dem
heute journal auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend da brauchst ein sturmtief
innerhalb von 24 stunden über
deutschland hinweg und erreicht morgen
bereits das baltikum die kräftigsten
windböen gibt sich östlich des tiefdruck
zentrums und mit den sturmböen von mehr
als 75 kilometer pro stunde geht es
schon heute nacht los zunächst im
südwesten in rheinland pfalz saarland
bis zum frühen morgen dann aber auch
hier in brandenburg und in sachsen auch
morgen über tag pfeift es kräftig weiter
im westen sind dann schwere sturmböen
drin im osten sogar orkanartige
sturmböen orkanböen beschränken sich
wohl auf die gipfellagen der
mittelgebirge
morgen abend ist es mit dem sturm schon
im wesentlichen vorbei dann gibt es noch
sturmböen über der ostsee und über der
nordsee es gibt doch viel regen im
schwarzwald können bis zu 30 liter regen
pro quadratmeter fallen sonst sind
kräftige schauer und gewitter unterwegs
heute nacht bei temperaturen zwischen 16
und 7 grad und morgen liegen die
temperaturen bei 10 bis 18 grad das wird
ein grauslicher donnerstag halten sie
sich von wäldern fern und machen sie
sich darauf gefasst dass der verkehr
beeinträchtigt wird am freitag heißt es
dann auch in norddeutschland danach geht
es deutlich ruhiger weiter guten abend